Now we said earlier,
the diagnosis is mapping from
data space to hypothesis space.
We also noted that although we may
start with the initial set of data,
proposals of specific hypotheses will
lead us to collect additional data.
Once we have some hypotheses for
explaining the available data,
then this hypotheses become
indices into treatment plans.
So the next step is to map the
hypothesis space to the treatment space.
In case of medical diagnosis,
this might be a set of therapies, or
a set of drugs.
In case of auto mechanics
the treatment space might consist of
replacement of various parts or
repair of various parts.
Note here in the power
of classification,
this was the space of percepts,
this was the space of actions,
this mapping is very complicated.
So we map the space of percepts into the
equal classes in these catergories So
we index the actions over the equal
classes in these catergories so
the data index the actions
of the data space.
As we exited the treatment,
we monitor it.
And depending upon the result
of this treatment,
we may need to collect additional data.
The treatment fails.
And the fact that the treatment
has failed is important data
that might also lead to
the collection of additional data.
Thus in case of auto mechanics,
if I replace a particular component and
the car still does not
function properly,
then that is useful data to know.
Because it suggests that the fault that
I thought would explain the malfunction
is probably not the right diagnosis.
>> We could also think of this last
phase as a type of configuration,
which we talked about last time.
Given a set of hypotheses
about illnesses or
faults with a car, we can then
configure a set of treatments or
repairs that best address
the faults we discovered before.